un mensaje fuerte y positivo de apoyo a
Ucrania eso fue lo que dijo el
secretario general de la otan durante la
Cumbre que se celebró en vilna la
alianza invitará a kiev a convertirse en
miembro pero solo Cuando cumpla las
condiciones
reafirmaríamos que Ucrania se convertirá
en miembro de la otan y acordamos
eliminar el requisito de un plan de
acción de membresía esto cambiaría la
ruta de un proceso de dos pasos a un
proceso de un solo paso también dejamos
Claro que emitiremos una invitación para
que Ucrania se una a la otan cuando los
aliados estén de acuerdo y se cumplan
las condiciones los mandatarios de los
países miembros de la alianza acordaron
simplificar el proceso de la futura
adhesión ucraniana pero bolo de mirt
zelensky sigue descontento y alegó que
la extendida negociación de su membresía
representa una motivación para que Rusia
continúe su terror en Ucrania nato la
otan le dará seguridad a
ucraniana Ucrania hará que la otan sea
más fuerte
a Ucrania Gloria lituania por su parte
el ministro de relaciones exteriores
ruso apuntó que el kremlin tomará
medidas ante la reciente expansión de la
alianza lanzando una amenaza a kiev
en primer lugar debemos investigar de
qué gama estamos hablando desde nuestro
punto de vista es una decisión
equivocada que tendrá consecuencias para
la parte ucraniana porque naturalmente
nos obligará a tomar medidas repetir una
vez más nuestro enfoque fundamental para
tales decisiones Esto no puede afectar
como proceder operación militar especial
solo pueden empeorar el destino del
régimen ucraniano de kiev Supongo sin un
cronograma firme ni las condiciones
claras la eventual membresía de Ucrania
la alianza sigue en